you know our boss chin you know no no I
thought to do don't boss this around
like this bike on here we go alright you
[ __ ] it's always like that clap no
there's no effort in its like this yeah
chin up soft hands that's a little
Chin's always here he's always on time
oh he's like a [ __ ] cyborg you never
have to worry it also makes iPhones on
his off times you know that I did not
know him and cat are running a [ __ ]
sweatshop out of here cats always here
to on time I know it's incredible I
appreciate that
appreciate that Vietnamese people didn't
amis I watched you genuinely almost
throwing up at that egg oh dude
people thought I was faking like no I
know yeah it's not faith I believe in I
didn't know that oh yeah like in college
when I don't have any of that like there
was like the scat babe thing going
around we're like you know girls or guys
eating [ __ ] yeah like that if it's a
thing in Asia yeah yeah it's not
American thing it's called scat babes
it's usually asian women who are down to
eat [ __ ] it's a type of porno yeah but
my friends would put it on my laptop as
a joke because they knew as soon as I
saw it I would throw up immediately well
cuz Rogan Rogan when the internet when
the internet was just starting
he had the Internet and I remember I
would make him go to see pictures of pit
bulls or saying and he said he said you
want to see how [ __ ] up the world is
now the Internet is here you want to see
what's [ __ ] up now I was like what he
goes alright and I just hear him
giggling he and this is back I think
about this this back in the day when you
had it took a long time to get a web
2001 I probably mm I don't know yeah
let's call it mm yeah and he's giggling
me and and I go what he'll stay on
stands out and then he goes okay come
and I come running in and I see this ass
and I see this Japanese guy and his hair
is tied up in a like a samurai de bun
he's going oh and all of a sudden I just
hear Rogen he can't come in the room
he's he's giggling with peeking around
the corner cuz he can't look at however
the hood and then he and then up some
slow Brown dainty Turner comes
he'll pee like honey or somebody melted
out of this female ass and the guy
begins to eat it mm-hm and Rogan starts
to gag like you are he's going and you
can't look at it I'm me I could look at
it but I've never been I've never been
the same
I'm not good with us I never be the same
but I went well there there it is that's
I remember him saying that's what you
that's the Internet he's now Joe boy
seemed the worst that's why I offer
it's the Yanks the kinky [ __ ] was like I
was like wow it was a seminal moment in
my life I have always been super weird
that stuff like I'm air used to love top
ramen noodles were top ramen like cup of
noodles yeah and my brother was like you
know they make that out of human sweat
like the seasonings from human sweat
that's why it looks like that I was
young I'm like wow I literally I haven't
had one since yeah that was many many
moons ago no you can't you can't if you
look at how many fly eggs and how many
flies and things are allowed in in in
quechua industrial food and ketchup
we hate bugs are in ketchup Google
Google hell you know Hines everyone
loves our hind I'm gonna get a Dodger
dog let me put my ketchup on it yeah
right
oh right yeah no just catch up and
there's bugs yeah all of the guess
always the case but bugs are good
probably not though nowadays no 30 fruit
fly eggs per 100 grams of canned corn to
insects but how many bugs are in ketchup
its science bro insects and you catch I
have insect fragments you know what
though who gives a [ __ ] I remember my
debt when my dad would cook for us one
of their kids he'd have like his nose
here is regular hair in it
like dancers here unless he bites
protein shut up Lee all right I can't
have here dude I can't have a nose hair
in my food but also let's don't have any
here in the right I can have because
it's protein just pick it out or eat it
okay all right dude yeah there you go 30
fruit fly eggs per 100 grams coffee ten
percent of beans infested oh yeah not
black rifle
we're bug free big as a bug free it's
America goddamn yeah you check yeah we'd
have them Russian be he check uh peanut
butter 50 and sake fragments again I
don't care man
are there insects give me the insects
that you are really squeamish about all
bees all bees
we're not days I don't kill any animals
I see a spider I don't kill it now as
you put it outside gentle giant right
but if I see an old Hornet a yeah with
the six-pack yeah in the long torso and
they have like it's like a [ __ ]
subway system from your face either tail
it's not gonna go black super is a
superhero B it's a cent it's like a baby
with armor nobody and they don't look
like a bi my God he's kind of cute buzz
around pollinates the earth that makes
sense we need B my joke and maybe they
live alone in the ground and I'm part of
the ecosystem they were put on the earth
to punish men for their sin correct
that's what that why else would you have
a horn and that's gonna sting you
multiple time yeah there you know they
don't sting and I know they're [ __ ]
there for death
yeah they stay in the fog yeah so
anyways these wars or not look at that
nothing that thing's a little [ __ ] I'm
talking about the one with the full
bodies chin those yellow Japanese always
on my Pepsi well six seven I'll melt
your face no no no no no sorry that's a
Japanese Hornet I'm looking for a no not
giant Hornets if you put in a what would
they be called look at the size that
[ __ ] Hornet though their house I'm
not working no that's on my timeout horn
I'm talking what do they call they have
the full BOTS they have like literally
they have like long ass tubing not trash
talker no man these are mud wasps no bro
they're in [ __ ] a very skinny body
and a lot look they're really long
they're long but they're everywhere
yeah I'm wasjust where there why is
there mud wasps though go to mud wasps
wasps no yeah but not your regular chips
well Austin there you go yes hey that
guy that's a mud wasp
yep nobody's getting never get out he
kind of looks like that same body that
one over there there you go the one with
the yellow legs yeah yeah yeah that's
what I see around my [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's oh I see you around my
neighborhood you know what I'm not
liking it no it's the only thing I'll
kill you get around my son I'm like
little water headed your way
boom yeah step on it now you need the
bug assault that's made not for flies
but for large outdoor insects they have
at your house sure dude that thing you
can look like more of a [ __ ]
listen they will kill they will kill
your wasps with salt
they'll blast his [ __ ] body into
smithereens and it's called the
bug-a-salt and
I'm a huge fan Brian walked on his house
shooting this yes I did I get 12 years
it's a beautiful invention I kill a lot
of flies and I want flies in my house I
want why do you have Chloe flies in the
house because and you know I never uh
flies in my cuz I don't clean I keep
things very dirty ya know not a lot of
bugs and got that thing I killed there's
a shitload of bug you think California
that thing will she like kill her or not
they well they had that's for flies they
have the more powerful one now lawn and
garden right there you [ __ ]
lawn and garden there you go bang that
thing will I think of one competence
over why does this show a but wasps
[ __ ] know why he not want to buy it
but I'm appreciating it invented by a
guy surfer artist and in Venice longtime
Venice resident he was like when he
invented stick crushing it apparently
crushing it or is that a nerf gun
without the bullets selling a lot of
them on Amazon apparently huge number
they should it's my favorite thing in
the world very long yeah yeah that's
right I remember when I was a kid my
grandma had the the fly zapper mm-hmm
you know the [ __ ] stupid fly zapper
yeah you don't really see those in our
and flies we just like yeah and they
just say you see those in the south now
the thing that I'm the most afraid of is
a centipede is a large side now you have
to worry about those so the flight the
flies are all over bro
yeah the flies and wasps were all over
ya as our boy coyote been stung by a
thing lately
I've been watching heavy not all of it
why cuz my children are says what has he
updated it I've seen him bees excel in
their mom but once you start putting his
hand in a great whites mouth and [ __ ]
yeah that's see what views are not
coyote well he did [ __ ] with a snapping
turtle but he didn't I think he didn't
let it eight hours ago
get him no we what's the last thing you
got stung Byers he over the stinging
thing to be move on probably looks like
he's moving on sense
well the biggest slug ever be bared okay
be man I'll get I think so you can only
do so much stinging right like you had
to move on Susie on the mammals getting
[ __ ] attacked by a mammals now it
looks like he's just educate
yeah that's mainly what he does yeah I
mean just what do you get stung that's
that's not full word to snake island
mm-hmm that when he gets stung that's to
educate people on it that's not to just
be this riled dude some steve-o type of
thing correct
see steve-o was getting cauliflower
trying to get on purpose from Chuck
Liddell he was he said yeah he sent me a
text going dude do you think this can
actually give me cauliflower get chucked
it up coming over I'm gonna have him
mess with my ear something needs to you
need to it for a while repeatedly yeah
but I'm just getting to a jiu-jitsu
class and just roll that would be well
while and repeatedly I don't think it's
good to get choked out like that because
they can [ __ ] up
no he's I can choke down all this oh he
did that this is so funny but also if
you have Chuck Liddell there haven't
punching there don't Chuck Liddell's not
really a golfer and like why have
chocolate eclairs oh what a [ __ ] hurt
our boy John Brenkus I told you playing
golf yeah he told me to I got knocked
out yeah kept saying twice now yeah yep
twice though okay talk good gettin old
have you seen what I'm gonna look like
when a little older Harvey's muddy yeah
Harvey stays in shape apparently Harvey
wakes up like four and swims for three
hours a day or some crazy yeah that's a
lie
yeah I know yeah I love people that say
they'll wake up really early I do you
wake up a 3-matic I don't know how you
do that Johnny full of [ __ ] probably
everybody lies about their height and
their and how much they think people lie
about their age their high and then also
their workout regimen and comics lie
about how much they're writing that's
the world I'm living in that's that's a
very good point and chin lies about
killing no lie I just don't say anything
don't say anything
I think cat just keeps quiet as she
downloads our darkest secrets and she's
gonna sell at the TMZ yeah that's right
he's got a treasure trove of our
behavior she blackmails us she's like
I'm gonna need 12 million dollars or I'm
blasting out all these big pigs all
these that you two keep sending each
other and for other reason Brian
included me on the group text that's
right an accident that's right
well nowadays you know anything drummed
up from whatever no they could Photoshop
anything well then judge Kavanagh like
when he was 16 years old and drunk I
mean you know now there you can dig into
anything when you're a kid you know
about that yeah yeah how about Bill
Cosby if I'm your kernel entrance in
there but you thought about no Cosby
going away DC he was still laughing so
he's going away yeah he's gonna appeal
that sentence well he's in prison
tonight
yes yeah 81 I'm blind what a fall 81 is
blind and you're gonna end your your
years inside that he's gonna die any day
now that's how it goes like and
obviously Joe Paterno didn't rape a
million women women but he was older
right and he was the coach of Penn State
but all the pressure that comes with
that and you're really old as [ __ ] and
he has two crazy eyes but you know I
give it under a year before that man
that is redemption it's like for the
women that were yeah their stupor story
[ __ ] do you see this mugshot throw up
here up here no the cameras not down
there all right
left eyes kind of focused you know what
[ __ ] it Lisi has the suspenders on damn
in a bummer of course it's a bomb it's
just it's the whole thing is yeah the
whole thing that's a little like Papa's
job Bobby I was black I'm like what the
[ __ ] is going your neighbor could be my
friend is a police officer and deals
with lots of different I mean he's a
special cop so he deals with
international fugitives child porn rings
counterfeiting all kinds of [ __ ] and he
said to me in when order and society
breaks down I promise you there are
people on your street and a block away
that would just take your take your
daughter and turn her into a sex slave
all that stuff I mean you're like and
hehe that that's how right I mean that
guy's a clinical psychologist and police
officers like detectives they live hey
they look at human being completely did
very differently I couldn't live like
that man yeah I like to view everyone
that with having the best intentions
yeah I think it's a weird way to view
the world too because if you do do that
because deaths are down if you look at
the media everything
sound so bad yeah economy's good jobs
are good actually things I've never been
better with technologies like it's and
look at that way or or you're that cop
could be wrong because he sees the worst
in people right of all time and he's
just wrong sure cuz your neighbors
haven't be awesome and maybe when
[ __ ] Armageddon comes like you're an
American Horror Story the new seasons
amazing and I would think I'm a purple
and you're a grey I'm not falling to
show you have no idea what I'm talking
about but anyways I'd like to think my
neighbors would rally and we'd [ __ ]
be fighting crime well you and I I think
I got probably can speak to you we look
at the best in people right I just trust
people in general I don't I don't really
trust people but yeah I do I mean I
always just yeah yeah III I always
assume you invest time in people that I
can look and go dude yeah it's alright
just assume the best in people
yeah you're probably less than that bad
more skeptical a bit a liability of mine
yeah forever and I don't think I'll ever
change I know it's just so yeah but um
and I think that's a good way to go
through life
agree but it's also it also can cost you
right you can get burned
you can wait Kashi like time yes it's
gonna cost you time and yeah but there
is this fundamental divide between some
people and and like some people either
look at the world is a dangerous place
other people look at the world is a safe
place and it can really have if I think
Einstein said that Einstein said the
most important decision you can make and
as a human being is whether or not the
world is fundamentally good or
fundamentally bad okay I think it's good
restrictions have a
two-and-a-half-year-old I view the world
as dangerous as [ __ ] well it's one thing
to be positive but you you can't be
positive at the expense of being a
little analytical critical like you
should know the difference between good
and right bad you should know be able to
spot when something seems off
right like somebody once somebody does
one thing and you're like that's a
pattern I'm saying they're right that's
when you and then you go I'm gonna keep
my distance people are weird yeah feel
like chin you trust people easily
I'm already bro 41 dude you're 40 bro 41
were you out on this before I used to
trust everyone I thought the world was a
beautiful place I was just like
everything's awesome and then you don't
anymore then when you get
older he's just start with like Brian
says you know you notice like these
patterns in people and then I pick up on
him and like no this guy's not good
it is like good but it's gonna be now
you're super skeptical [ __ ] I'm still
just I'm so good but cat where you out
on this you're still you're humming
still bushy bright-eyed nope I've I've
met some shady people in my time
California is a sunny place for shady
people rich that's ready remove Elan
Musketeers ah again sorry you were
thinking uh yeah I've met some shady
people in my time really yeah
how so first of all so okay well nobody
new families I'm gonna tell y'all story
oh yes I have an uncle who came over to
my house when I was younger this was
like my parents first home and it was a
big like housewarming party location how
old are you any detail I was like nine
ten
okay I have an a great uncle who came in
and robbed my mom of her purses and sold
them to other women that she worked with
at the coffee shop Wow that's my mom
found out because she's like my bags are
gone also why does this girl I work with
have my bag with that spine on it was he
was he a drug addict or anything no he
was just channeling his kids to this day
don't know about it my mom didn't make a
big deal just doesn't say anything to me
I thought this one go way darker I've
seen way too many I can't taste a weight
I've seen way too many buddy and he came
over yeah and I'm glad just me me yes I
thought sounds like aa witch right this
no no I thought I was gonna go we do see
the world in a bad way now well it means
older uncle that's not no
I have a family friend who brought his
kids to shoot a guy at a coffee shop
because he owed him drug money hmm
no there's stuff like that as well so
you don't trust people to unjam but its
own money maybe I'm gonna hey you got a
slap a [ __ ] I mean I just don't get him
in the ladies like so I'm talking about
sociopaths and a woman I know pretty
well and she's awesome and and she goes
oh my brother's one of those I went
really and what do you mean oh um he's
generally a terrible person and does the
crazy [ __ ] you can imagine I go like
what he goes well my parents were on
vacation he tried to sell their house
from under them and I see what's the
house on sale Fords their signature
Jesus grace and before he came back yeah
their house because he wanted the money
and then he was like this when they were
like my bad and he goes he was what
trying now whatever I know you were that
attached the house I'm trying to get a
good price for it Jesus Chris yeah that
kind of guy and then somebody was dead
and somebody one of the family members
had died was very sad people were crying
and he came in and he came in and
they're like easy with the noise noise
noise Jesus Christ isn't it's just a bad
guy she said he's a bad person have you
ever dated any bad guys cat no I don't
like I don't like the generic bad boys I
don't want you don't know well bad boys
going things hell it means bad guys like
you kind of tell they have a very
specific look and very specific demeanor
about really yeah I mean it's growing up
I had I knew a lot of guys who would
like rob houses around their schools
like holdup families and like rob them
stuff like that I'm like you know what
I'm good I'm not doing it on that yeah I
had a lot of cousins who used to like
listen to that song by Akon locked up
and they would sing about how their
boyfriends in juvie like free Sony like
bruh no wow that's not good you hold a
family up Hospital Rob no there's bad
boys in this criminal cat I was talking
about like maybe the edgy dude happy
won't tattoo long
I'm sorry edg's I might leave my guns
lying around as opposed to in a safe
like that just makes me want to have a
gun in my belt all the time okay some
[ __ ] comes in and tries to hold me
hostage
ya know so I can get into my stance I
remember I remember there was a dude who
used to talk about how he was a
mercenary and he was a dork and when I
was at the dog park back in the day I
used to have my dog at the dog park yeah
this is 22 years ago and I think his
name is Howie and he said great name and
I said well you know I did buy some guns
in case somebody comes into my house and
he goes that's how I shot my robber and
I went okay here goes
I go what you doing tell the cops this
but heard and try get in the door I set
up I set up and put a mount put my
dresser there put my gun on there came
in bang bang
no mad at that I was like okay that's a
little crazy but he was so proud of you
kid I would be proud believe him
how about that no cuz you're gonna set
up a mount and do all that it's too much
I was like I don't believe ya know ya
have no problem shooting people that try
to kill me your house
uh no don't shoot him when there was TV
in their hand don't you when they're
walking away from you yeah you'd be
alright
coming at you your house should be all
right all right no not always
I know your lawyer a friend told you
this not my cops that came to my house
the gun shop got house was burglarized
the gun shot got actual cops cops Santa
Monica Police Ike in my house told me I
said so what should I have done and
that's from your house and he's a threat
to your family can shoot my spot now now
statistically even when you do that and
you're in the right even when you're
dead and you're in the right it's gonna
cost you on average and this is
statistically about 200 grand and legal
fees why the family's gonna sue you
you're gonna be doing all that baby so
it is it's always going to be maybe I'm
not going to jail no no and it's not
like I'm like I better not shoot him I
don't be out 200 grand you you know what
Brian told me somebody's leaving your
house and you shoot him in the back you
can go to jail for that and people have
a harp sent yeah he's not just cameras
but also it's your word against
is but if he's I'm saying if he's
walking oh is it running if he's moving
away with the TV in his hand in your
house and he's going away from you and
you shoot him in the back that is eight
you're criminally liable you can be
absolutely sure you're convicted for
that so make sure he's coming toward you
mm-hmm I always go freeze freeze face me
and I use a crossbow
he's a crossbow that would [ __ ] hurt
yeah well apparently I've talked to
Cameron Haynes and I think I talked to
Rogan about that like the arrows going
so fast it goes through you it remember
we talked about Karen Haynes on this
show what happens is you'll look down
and you'll go what too late yeah that's
not on the show yeah if it can kill a
grizzly bear you you're not gonna do too
well
well none of that stuff you only hit
with no not with those how about the
arrow is that Rogan was showing us those
those [ __ ] that there's like razor
blades
well let's don't get down that [ __ ] man
no you know guys it's so easy to destroy
butts so hard to build huh
and I think that's the theme of this
podcast Oh Oh God
now Brennan has a beautiful face but I
could [ __ ] cuz I box flatten that
nosey posy
maybe cat what are you doing this
weekend what are you doing the weekends
this weekend
I'm gonna go see one of my friends shows
back at USC and then my name shows oh
well I was a theater major so I'm gonna
go see my friends perform hold on oh did
I open Pandora's box I didn't know you
were a theater major yeah I went to USC
for theater get the [ __ ] door last name
B no you don't know a lot about it
what's your last name leave ya Kat Lee
it's a great name actually you have a
very good strong voice do you sing no I
don't I just have a very deep voice you
have a good voice a very voice for radio
for sure yeah yeah um or like even like
you know Apple commercials that's so
cool I got you could talk me into buying
a goddamn Apple phone can you sure say
say say Apple phones all you're ever
need to talk
distance Apple phones all you'll ever
need to listen to talk long distance
yeah before she [ __ ] that box yeah
other than to just say Apple phones
Apple phones
it's nice thought out Apple phones Apple
phones okay well yeah super weird
yeah theater major you still want to be
an actress right now I'm trying to
figure that out I would like to do
theater but I mean that's kind of hard
and listen and this place time
interesting Asian isn't that you know
the girl who does she's having Sarah the
girl who works on below the belt
Showtime Squad just sold her script yeah
because I crazy Richard Hollywood tends
to like a very specific type of Asian
they like that until you come along
change their mind the half-asian play
victim right now like the Olivia Munn's
of the world you know like that half
white oh girl no cuz did you saw crazy
rich Asians I mean there isn't a [ __ ]
there's like how Hafiz in there yes nor
the stories hop isn't really the guy
he's how do I say a lot of a lot of
people in there are half but you could
still do it cat you don't want not try
because you think everyone's looking for
Olivia Munn no it doesn't mean I'm not
trying to have a very specific his
name's Henry Henry Goulding oh you know
who's really fine Remmy hi in there yes
fine let me hi Mambo isn't it
it's a good call my knees in Swedish yes
there he is that's the same one Remy hi
yet search these trends so now that
crazy rich Asians is killing it you're
gonna see him in power he's fine he
looks alright to me looks a little odd
very wide go ahead
so that's a white head just tell me what
his eyes are so really it's him maybe
that's a bad foot maybe that's a bad pic
what else nice hair looks like [ __ ]
alright means give me another one no
because the other onions were Vikings
him him in Marco Polo yes him in regular
life and I can maybe I'm saying grow
grow some hair in your face proberly
here it's the long hair ah
he needs facial hi is he a big guy I
don't know I think I think it's probably
your size it's funny I say I might as
well go to get a height chin he's cute
he's definitely cute I'm he's not a
heartthrob cat so don't throw that word
out there right in this lies so he's by
5 well not everybody can be Jason Momoa
or Brian Kelly he's he's the
best-looking guy I've ever seen
personally bachelor good-looking dude I
was pretty guerrilla when I first made
to met Jason Momoa when he's doing a
sci-fi show nobody knew him I said the
road to I said to Grillo I went for he's
the best looking guy I've ever seen am I
wrong about that this guy Jason my mom's
like he's the [ __ ] coolest looking
human being I've ever seen
look at me come on come on
and then his wife was it she said well
any crap no yeah she's choosing the
Cosby Show wait she was on The Cosby
Show yeah
what is she with Lenny before and they
have a daughter named Zoe yes Joe is
very stages of them was that anyone
who's young yeah yeah you used to be on
Baywatch
did they do all the student no he does
terrace he's gone yeah no they're all
shredded like that Brennan khal drogo
man I'm a fan of Drago but do you think
B what you telling me don't shatter my
I'm gonna ask you and don't be
exaggerating do you think there are
steroids in Hollywood do you think
Aquaman may be injected every Gold's Gym
steroid into his ass don't you that I
went to he might be the kind of guy that
could just get big as [ __ ] though right
I got it I doubt it
no for me to get in this shape that he's
in on the far right
like that big and lean I'd need help you
need help why not
you're not hurt I knew it I agree if I
talk looking David Aires called me I was
a caveman won't you be this badass the
moving you'd be jacked as possible and
shredded I might belong to the guild I'd
love to see you do that I'd love to see
I don't know where I'd go to get the
Jews I do I know two doctors in
particular no they're just give me dis
testosterone I need like the Juju's like
I'd go to n go to gym
I know I know way out Joey Johnny Ramone
he's the guy he's that black shady he's
the world expert on yeah but does he
deliver it he makes it alright well
there's um you know what you don't have
the balls we should go and do that my
buddy who's my age that will actually a
little younger good athlete goes he goes
dude they don't know great guy said then
he goes hey bro let's do steroids like
what do you I want [ __ ] traps I was
like all right it was great I can't wait
to go on the juice don't feel like I
need it right now you know what you're
like 60 might be too late what do you
think then all the piping and stuff so
afraid to [ __ ] with my endocrine system
because I feel healthy well then but why
you just want to do it cuz you wanna be
big at 51 yeah that's a bummer it's sad
how sad I want to be like if you get
that and you buy a yellow Corvette
Convertible and you're like all jacked
by Ryan's trap so hard that's why I
don't want to do it but you know maybe I
could start fighting in the UFC
maybe bro that's the goal yeah
priorities chin have you ever thought
about doing steroids the size a better
half like though gives you an idea how
big Venice no but see Archie sounds like
a good idea do you have a you know what
I feel like anyone in this room
including cat chin would benefit the
most from testosterone I don't want to
take that side cuz we're gonna box I
know what can it be juiced up bro gotta
be great good that'll work out first
I've ever thought about it Jin CRT you
should looking a lot of weights to do
you have a good body you could get
[ __ ] Jack I probably could yeah I did
I lifted before and I got pretty big
they used to be throwing a pounds Brian
but that was just fat I know but you
were big dude I'm saying but you never
considered doing a nice
I'm serious TRT sounds like a good idea
now what did you do it you have to go
check my [ __ ] on you have to [ __ ] it's
gonna help your energy how much it costs
either month how much I've heard no I
mean if you want to do it with the
doctors that's what I would do it's not
that expensive
no yeah underground dirty you don't do
underground you can get your levels
checked and have a doctor you get your
blood you know if you don't want to go
most insurance doesn't cover it matter
of fact use it slow if you're diagnosed
with it yeah they might have 41 you
might be on I haven't counted out I'm
telling the table full of people I go
you know you know when you're up
somebody's on trt it's what I want to do
I don't my skin turn this negative
people gonna you know that somebody's
doing it and the guy goes the guy's
[ __ ] is that true when I go yeah I
guess huh I go yeah I mean you can tell
I think it's cool
and he looks over at me and he goes hey
dude I'm on he's on some insane amount
of us I'm on [ __ ] three hundred
thousand the [ __ ]
he's like I'm doing [ __ ] the [ __ ] can
you tell I go no I can't oh yeah [ __ ] no
people think TR T's like it's steroids
it's just getting your levels to normal
I mean if you take more than you need
that's just what I would want to do
that's what you want to do I would want
to do oh uh you would want it be cool
free good Jeana why don't we make a
segment of chin getting jacked I would
literally do out of everything we said
before that's the that's part of the
thing I do most trt Wow more than cool
boxing although we should buck stuff we
could do both I go hand in hand I mean I
should box without CRT though this like
DC yeah I'm like airy gonna like I just
disappeared do all the road you want
chin you guys know there's no testing
but I told a bit to take the night off
I tell you what you guys know if you're
really serious I would like to talk to
the guy anyway from my future yeah I'll
find the man who helps all the
CrossFitters and all the guys who do
steroids if you guys you're overthinking
it there's there's a doctor I mean I
know a million doc she can do it he has
over thinking well you should I get a
blood checked they write you a
subscription
yeah I'm in a prescription yeah and you
take a shot once a week yeah that's
right that's all it is
you guys are putting this you put in
tests offs testosterone a pedis no but
he wants to steroids no no I want to do
testosterone okay just
in that winstrol steroids steroids are
testosterone derivatives yeah they're
deca and of all it's all testosterone
right that's not what you can get from
the doctor though
I like the legal stuff though so if it's
legal then your alien wants to attack a
deca animal that's right
he said it I could never be awful were
you ever tempted to do it when you were
training yeah I just can't afford it I
didn't you know I didn't I didn't have
that stuff yeah I can afford it is that
what it was
yeah can afford it man mmm definitely
would have done a problem but you
weren't afraid of it or you weren't sort
of like I've been around it my entire
entire life yeah yeah we have some kind
of engine yeah we do
let's start off with cats first this is
sort of sort of current sort of not so
Brendan said he didn't know about Jackie
Chan's love child
did you and drop some I did well the
reason we when we walked in there we
were talking about who are we talking
about and you said oh that's like Jackie
Chan for me I loved him I said he is
Smith oh we talked about Will Smith yes
I can yeah and I was talking about the
fact that I love Jackie Chan my parents
hate Jackie Chan because of what he did
to his love child he had an affair with
an Asian beauty queen in China Chinese
beauty queen had a child with her while
he was still married to his wife and now
she his daughter is going around saying
that she is homeless because people are
homophobic and she blames her dad as
well but a lot of people are just saying
that she doesn't want to work she's just
crazy
yeah she's crazy let me get my peepers
on her what she look like here also the
reason why they don't like Jackie Chan
is because he left his daughter like one
Chinese penny which is [ __ ] up we just
thought she on the left or right do you
think that I have no idea seriously I
don't know did he see Asian
why are you Chinese people had a child
spitballin here is it the white girl no
well people are gonna think you're
racist
look man Brennan doesn't see co humans
he's so not prejudice you do beautiful
humans which ones related to change
Brendon is obviously the one on the left
and I'm all that because of the hair oh
wow because I had one the left has a
similar I apply black are on the right
I think she's bi I don't know I can't
tell either I can't see I can't see
color or anything or features oh wow
she's a cute girl or cute young man
whatever is a well I mean we get a
testosterone ask her where she gets hers
no but she's she's having a hard time
yes right now I just be lazy yeah a lot
of people are saying that she's just
lazy because people who are close to her
saying that she should just go get a job
if she wants to be financially stable
start doing [ __ ] stunts like your dad
with his dad so his dad has has not
doesn't have any do with her her dad but
yes she just have dude vital no child I
can promise something that my buddy once
I was like what if someone showed up
said this is your kid I'd be like if
some woman did that I'd be very excited
and I would take that kid in as my own
that's what I would do I got no problem
with that
like why wouldn't you it's your kid man
so what yes take you did your thing but
take care of your business
is because China's conservative yeah I
know it is I am so it's nothing to do
with it they don't people know how about
this little piece of trivia on Chinese
TV you're not allowed to kiss no kissing
a lot well you know yes absolutely no
kissing allowed very very puritanical
very strict but yeah this is there are
strong social norms around this but I
don't know maybe but who knows the full
story maybe is that Jackie Chan sundial
rugby that's a good point
who knows all I know is Jackie Chan made
some amazing movies and if you made
rumble in the Bronx you can do no wrong
in my book I forgive him for this
me too what is this video what are they
doing here oh it's just them to sob
sorry they they are my buddy
yes how did they don't have any money
living now the girl on the left speaks
Chinese - listen to this girl the girl
on the Left speaks fluent Chinese hi I'm
Jackie Chan's daughter
we've been homeless for a month
mobic parents we pretty much slept under
a bridge and other things you know um
yeah I've asked all my friends for help
Oh my family for help and everyone just
keeps sending us to the direction of
shelters where they know we will be
split up we will be split up if we have
to go to any kind of government are they
in China what I mean yeah and now no one
is responding to my phone calls
yeah sorry come on keep going
let's get weird I don't I don't even
understand what's going on because we've
gone to the police we've gone to police
food banks LGBTQ community shelters
during America yeah her English is too
good she keeps on hurting this video
because we don't we don't know what to
do at this cell those thousand books
behind you no man show people that two
people in love that have true love are
trying to get split apart how would you
try and get a job
Joey Sam split you apart what I don't
understand it I love her I love you you
know it's no one's doing anything cool
man no one's stopping you guys from
[ __ ] each other in their bridge or
whatever you want to do sell all those
books behind you and don't pick your
nose like you're on the left now all I
can think about is that woman's eyebrows
need to grow a little bit longer exactly
you don't know the girl no loud eyebrows
like batteries don't trust somebody with
eyebrows like that you ain't living
under a bridge if he's tweaking your
eyebrows like that I mean those are does
hurt like you can like she's very pretty
girl on the right doesn't like Jackie
Chan yeah and the one on the left is
very pretty I mean it could be you don't
think she's pretty Miss Rose brand we're
back sell those shitty paintings behind
you sell that hat rack that's behind you
there's a hat rack you get a lot of
money for the high rack with no hooks so
sound up full so that wouldn't Paul
because like everyone is against this
ruling force to fail I mean I don't know
nope
no idea don't know you know what you two
should do maybe get a job you go to a
shelter they don't go you gays splitter
to you here you can you ladies have to
split a couple gays that's it you're
going to Florida you're staying in New
York
Food Bank I'd hire you guys you don't
look like they're now you look lazy you
know that when you're so dawn of details
but when somebody went kind of tell when
somebody's when somebody can't get
anybody on the phone right so there is a
prisoner I was helping I was uh I was
spending some time I was talking to him
yeah I was trying to help him and help
him come up with a plan for when he gets
out yeah and the guy who was at the jail
who was worked at the jail who I was in
contact with said to me call me and said
hey hey bro you're wasting your time
with that guy and I said why he goes his
mother doesn't even speak to him his
mother won't take his calls and I was
like thank you very much mom like sucked
now he said he said nobody in the jail
talks to him his mom I was like no
wonder much yeah okay hey now did you
continue to send that man money for the
six years did you smuggle drugs in your
ass for that man I was in New York I did
I did not produce conjugal visits and
suck them off there I endure why I had
you have no right to split us up no
right
you have no right to no right to split
us up and it was under a bridge and no
one will talk to us that's always yeah I
am Brian what else she got I don't know
why I was laughing at that four dudes
think it's a stupid
so rapper lil zan was rushed to the
hospital and his fans were really
worried about him because he was a big
fan of Mac Miller they were afraid that
he was in the hospital due to a drug
overdose okay what do you want on social
media and said no I'm good I actually
got rushed to the hospital because I ate
too many hot cheetos do we buy this well
I do my another kid with
I know this to all the young generation
and is in is into pills and face tattoos
it's insane yeah and I say old as [ __ ]
ting that's for real he's a big rapper
he was dating some chick and they broke
up
let me see another picture of him please
yeah he was dating Miley Cyrus's younger
sister no nitrous and she try selling
her tears for $12,000 post-breakup did
sell no she put it up as a joke somebody
made a gofund of me trying to raise
$12,000 to buy her a bottle this kid was
shut down how old is this kid huh 13 oh
my how long how old is he oh look I know
he must be a no come on but so he said
with the house because eight to me huh
he said that it tore something in his
stomach and he started throwing up blood
I don't know if I believe it or not I
tell you something I eat a shitload of
hot cheetos cat my girl she's Mexican is
ah and they love hot cheetos they love
hot cheetos yeah they [ __ ] love hot
cheetos
she's Cheetos non [ __ ] stop no one
throws up from hot cheetos bike blood
last year there was a girl who was
rushed to the hospital to take her
gallbladder out because she ate too many
hot cheetos and talk is it that factor
on instagram who makes like these bring
up hot cheeto girl she dissed girls 500
pounds looks like Jabba the Hutt and she
[ __ ] loves flamin hot cheetos and she
would grind him up and then put him on
like corn and put it on like mac and
cheese yes yes look at her oh no it was
not her look at her I need to see her
this is a Mario Lopez's Instagram please
go to her page though all the kids right
there huh Wendy's eating show all she
does is eat hot cheeto weird [ __ ] hot
cheeto Pizza while she stepped up her
production keep going there's some legit
one I liked what she was doing there I
know no no not to see that what the corn
ones like kind of got her pop in for a
second she is
I'll do this you just say start the
first process genius dude she is so
thick I can't finish the she's let me
see this she's every I love her cuz she
owns it if you think she ain't getting
laid you're crazy there are a lot of
guys then I'm crazy but she's not even
doing it keep going to this just this
[ __ ] on there delicious
there's her there that's the big one
there you go oh that's a little video
though we just saw the video of her yeah
I could have watched that all day I
don't know why'd I really good you liked
it yeah these videos are really popular
they actually came from South Korea it's
called mukbang what's it very change
Aventis know there are tons of YouTube
channels where people just eat in front
of a camera I want to get away they get
paid did you just leave your culture or
just leave the world sometimes like I
get so exhausted with how weird
everything is now click on this video it
makes me feel sick I'm not gonna be home
I did what just smash up someone's
ingredients and put it on [ __ ] three
Mexicans been doing this forever what is
that that she's eating Ango that time
that when she doesn't that's replaying
that's incredible
I'm definitely gonna be watching this
yeah a lot of people make money this way
now they should oh there she carries a
lot of weight in her face I'm just
stating the obvious I'm not trying to be
limited that's that's uh that's
incredible and good for her I mean it's
one there's like obviously she's a huge
fan of food off the author thing so
surely you know how can I make a
business out
and she's doing the damn thing how many
fathers does she have chin she it's not
weird we've um okay we even watched him
for a while maybe go click on are you -
does she have a bunch of YouTube maybe
that's where she got big at there has to
be a full videos how many subscribers
does she have eight hundred twenty-four
thousand somebody eating but she has the
kind of face that you want to see eat
let's not say opposite right come on
Brendan wait hold on like I want my chef
to look like her but I don't want to I
don't want to watch Sony obviously
830,000 to disagree with you obviously
over a million almost a million people
disagree look at this that makes me feel
sick she's doing what my chef to look
like that I don't want you throw up our
eggs in this and I and I can't stop
looking at this is so [ __ ] weird
people are into this town do videos of
you just [ __ ] eating salads or some
[ __ ] what are you I think I will do that
and they're just dance like this girl
that's amazing head is almost that's why
- oh good for her is that mark hunt with
a wig on what I mean I don't know how we
have star on this Oh cuz little zen went
to the hospital for cheetos oh yeah he's
full of [ __ ] he OD done drugs otherwise
ow - Oh d-don't [ __ ] wine gums and
coffee yeah what else we got so Six
Flags in st. Louis is having a
competition for Fright Fest right now
we're that they're having six
contestants stay in a coffin for more
than 30 hours weather wins wins the
coffin $300 and season passes $300 [ __ ]
you $300 is it really nice tents as it
sounds from the title it's actually you
get one
bathroom break every hour you have your
meals in the coffin and you have you can
have your phone on you so it's like I'm
claustrophobic but I think they probably
just like sitting in it like the same
way I'm sitting right now I don't have
to like close that's what it sounds like
bad I would say I want to see how long
you can just lie there in the dark
they'll be horrible see six feet Vito
let us put dirt on you we'll get you out
well no you here for a little while or
maybe put a two just to the top I got
the to do I'm going to Six Flags next
week on my day off I'm finally not
traveling next weekend we're gonna stick
flags I pail obsessed with it I would
not do that in three hours [ __ ] that
what else right just three hundred
dollars no Jesus Christ so Kanye West
went on a social media tirade about how
he wants the option to opt out of
showing his followers and his likes on
social media I support this really I
support Kanye started you tell me Brian
so Kanye goes man I think we should be
able to show how many likes or how many
followers people have he was because the
younger generation is putting too much
emphasis on it and people have low
self-esteem and commit suicide because
they don't have a hundred thousand
followers when this girl does or it
makes people feel bad about themselves
right which I think you can blue check
people celebrities athletes and that's
fine but we don't need to show how many
followers this person has compared to
this person also in school it's one way
kids bully kids like what's the best
that comes from him I don't get I agree
with you man I think I think when you're
hurt there's more harm than good their
self-worth is tied to you know the
number of likes you have the number on
your back and did you listen which is
which which is a bad thing like yeah
especially this generation is so into
their phones if you take away that then
you know I think did you listen to Teddy
Atlas on Rogen No one of the best
interviews I've ever heard for a long
long time he talks about that kind of
like what boxing did for young people
even though he's a brain damaged yeah
but so does drugs and so does alcohol
when you're in the hood
and he said well
it teaches you what you're about you
know it also teaches you it gives you
self worth and that's the most important
thing he said there's a lot of different
kinds of poverty especially the poverty
where you think you're worth nothing and
there are a lot of people like that it's
kind of an interesting thing and I think
when your self-worth is tied to these
artificial ideas of social media how
many likes you have how much attention
that's everyone that's everyone's
there's all the kids so why why not take
out that kind of social structure where
kids don't have to worry about that then
after oh my god the high school
quarterback has 300 followers I have
three I'm such a loser
when because now you can quantify where
you're at in society right right it's
not good there's no there's no positives
from this now there's zero positives if
you have a dope page cool man people who
come to it keep posting you know
I just I don't see the benefits of it I
don't at all I think we were down a
weird Road I think Kanye's right and
this is coming from a guy was a Jay
Gillian followers yeah he says some
crazy [ __ ] be all system brilliance yeah
yeah he's getting older he's got did
they say anything though did what did
the he's trying to reach out to
Zuckerberg right now and a few others I
think he was able to get the CEO of
snapchat on text yeah but if you're
Facebook and they're like well no
people'll actually love that it's why it
works you know so I think he's trying to
have a conversation with the biggest the
creators of these apps but that don't
set Facebook Instagram like that he's
building schools in Chicago that's all I
got it here to love them that's [ __ ]
awesome what else we got so a flight
from Mumbai hock what a bunch of
passengers felt really sick on this
flight from Mumbai because the pilot
forgot to depressurize the plane Mumbai
India everybody Bombay right so after
the flight left a lot of the passengers
started to feel sick some people started
to have nosebleeds some people started
bleeding out of their ears yeah and once
customers started complaining the pilot
finally realized that he forgot to
depressurize the plane and they had to
have the little air masks
I forgot to pressurize it oh yeah so
when you when you lose but so when you
lose cabin pressure if you fly and
certainly our jobs fly sixty thousand
feet in the air usually you're flying at
thirty two thousand when you lose cabin
pressure I'd say sixty five thousand
feet
blood your blood boils at room
temperature what's yeah so when you lose
cabin pressure you'll die immediately
because your blood will begin to boil
right away so that's because of pressure
cabin pressures what the [ __ ] happens
with these people are they okay they're
okay problems when the pilot is the plot
of final destination well they have this
let's see let's see the video
what's wrong with the pilot the pilot
just forgot just negligence holy [ __ ]
man
every single person my ears are bleeding
it's I don't I'm not I'm not somebody
who's sued I don't sue people but in
this case I'd have to be like dude I got
blood in my ears dude I just got it I
need I need a private Jeff Kim what
might be just wet my feet a little bit I
mean I need first class for the rest of
my day in my favorite so I want a free
ticket every time I fly to Mumbai yeah I
mean that would be certain Airlines
she's like I'm not gonna fly in the air
that often so unless I was Indian so in
that sense but I'm not you gotta wet my
beak with some cash here's bleedin what
else you got all right this Michael
Rapaport suing barstool I know because
of herpes allegations damn money a
little mark on his mouth hold on so they
out him that he has herpes they're
making fun of them have for having
herpes
so he must have said they made t-shirts
with him in a clown face and yes this is
what bar stool does like but bar stool
hey be careful this grabs my boy bar
stool my guys as well I'm a fan of both
of those people and he said she and Mike
so they owe him money because they had a
deal in place and they fired Rappaport
yep
but rapport suing them's a little bit of
a bad look but they also are money too
so I don't I don't know the business I'm
Switzerland in this so this is actually
I guess you can't pants the suit alleges
yeah there's a blog post written by
Smith declaring a rapport a fraudulent
sack of [ __ ] and a creepy herpes riddles
failure I'm sure it's more for the money
though that he's owed if allegedly oh
yeah that's tough I mean but with
Barstow and though the environment we're
in you know they're pros right there 18
to 36 bros and they have the biggest bro
fanbase you know
out there they they do hate reviews and
sell shitload 40,000 paper used is a low
production they you know the some of the
podcasts are the biggest in the world
some days they beat us not always but
some day they beat us some days we beat
them right so they do well in podcasting
tonight they their whole brand is huge
yeah
the stoolies and I'm fans of them but
living in the current culture we live in
if you're gonna be an all bro centric
business people are gonna throw shade
your waste specially today guys [ __ ]
within me to movement so now you have
girls suing them right say no the
environment was horrible well you okay
that's like you know you you that's like
in mad that Hooters wants to show your
tits you applied to Hooters what's your
take on what do you feel about this diss
Brett Kavanaugh thing the the idea that
he's 36 years ago he was apparently
stumbling drunk got on top of a girl
pulled out her clothes covered her mouth
and then [ __ ] wasn't no he just was on
top of her and then somebody jumped on
both of them and he fell off but they're
they're saying that he should lose his
job and should not be in court not be a
Supreme Court now in high school I
listen but you know that's a real thing
and now there are two other women said
but now there's other women killed I'll
say in this one here's a woman said he a
beauty engaged an abusive behavior he
got drunk but he was 1660 yeah I worry
about I don't like that but I also don't
know I don't know Kavanagh at all I
don't know what have details to comment
on that
what I do know is we need people and
businesses like barstool in this world
where everyone they're trying to house
watching this morning like with the NFL
how about just a [ __ ] nation now and
the NFL and all concussions yeah you
mean [ __ ] grown men running each
other some guys you can have some
concussions that's that's what it is
do you want to live without boxing do
you want to live in a world where with
BOTS animes gonna be fine no one's
touching that but with the NFL America
sport you want to throw all these
penalties and then not tell them how to
tackle and change the game it's be and
the players don't have a problem with it
the players like well no we know what
we're signing up there we've been doing
this all our lives we're sure it's all
it's deciding the owners going they're
not it's society going nope we got to
protect these guys and the ratings are
down the owners are going to hole
the only people get hurt are the
quarterbacks that [ __ ] with our money
they're not worried about their safety
right so this whole thing stems from no
one's worried about anyone's safety then
it fells very aware what they're signing
up for everyone including the NFL owners
different they just don't want their
quarterbacks getting hurt - it affects
the bottom line but then a society is
going all footballs dangerous but yet no
[ __ ] man yeah but we're again with with
Kavanagh everyone's worried about when
you 16 do it so the man should lose his
[ __ ] job we sexy man are you the same
person when you were 16 I don't remember
being 16 bars - is there a problem that
bar stool is full of bros and they make
outlandish claims and common guys total
we need that there's a there's a lame
for that they're not hurting anyone yes
they have
the hottest girls that the smoke shows
of the week they say crude stuff yeah
guys talk like that's right when you
shouldn't live in a world we have to
censor bar stool we have to censor the
NFL we do when we go back to someone
being 16 we're not just let me we don't
live in there we're trying to pull us
towards now my god are they denying bar
stools and everything with force
they're trying there's no rule and
applause rules never been bigger right
bar stools ever been bigger fighting
kids never been bigger a couple bros we
talk about dicks about whatever football
still killer MMA's big if these big
boxing Hollywood still ran by dudes hate
to tell you if you're trying to fight
something that you're fighting it and I
agree there should be some sort of level
playing field but the same time - you
can't just take away everything that's
been built there cuz of a couple more on
the other thing I think is pretty
outrageous is California's legislature
spirited by our governor has said any
company in California that's that's held
publicly has to have women on its board
so it's a mandate although where you'll
get fired it's fine so so in other words
if you're a company regardless of
whether you're confident or not your
board has too many men so you have too
many dicks so we need vagina that that's
the delineation not competence so we
have to have gender equality and it's
going to be forced on you regardless of
whether or not you can do the job or not
that to me is the craziest government
overreach I've ever heard it's insane
how about if you're good for the job
regardless of what
you are what you are I don't give a [ __ ]
of you our transgender if you're good if
you're if you're the best person for the
job give them the job that's what I
believe and you know anyway agree what
else we got
this making a murderer - yes it's coming
out October 19th and they're focusing on
getting Brendan Dassey free from jail
like it's gonna be week on Motorz that
guy on the left
that's the murder oh that's him back
when he was younger that's when he got
busted yeah they're all super dumb super
not smart Brittany I was really I was
super they're super not blue genius you
don't need to be PC with this that
Brendan kid I [ __ ] hate his name's
Brendan he's a [ __ ]
well he's actually got a condition like
yeah no it's not stupid
no he's slow his brain doesn't work if I
was gonna make Wrestlemania after cream
but he was boring Penn right so we had
to be a little bit maybe you know no
it's true he's not all there
yeah tough to beat the RZA making murder
cuz it all if all it does focus on
Brendan Dassey although they're trying
to get him free I can't get enough of
this I'll watch the [ __ ] out of it
I like the way they go yeah yeah that's
how they say hi yeah yeah yeah I'll
watch stuff yeah [ __ ] out of that what
else you get X month all right this one
were Tom Segura on a special disgrace
use the R word we can say it I'm sure
but just for now we'll call it the R
word each art [ __ ] [ __ ] so there
was a website this one here the
disability scoop they talked about it
good for Netflix huh good for the next
Lex it's just a freedom of expression
god damn it okay so someone a Harvard
lawyer wrote to the CEO of Netflix Reed
Hastings and he said how disgraceful it
is how terrible is to use that word he
wanted him to change it but Reed
Hastings stood up for what Tom Tudor so
you Hastings good reasons that you stood
up yeah and here's the here's basically
what you said here our view is that even
though many fine Tom Segura Conor
Terfel in this instance they fall within
the bounds of creative expression as
part of a stand-up comedy performance
certain portions of any creative work
including stand-up comedy can and do
offend and are intended to evoke a range
of responses
Bravo Hastings as an on-demand service
no one has to watch any particular show
on Netflix we offer a wide range of
perspectives and voice on our service
and work hard to provide context and
tools give to give our members a higher
degree of choice and control over what
they and their families watch yeah you
don't have to watch is awesome thank you
thank you I think it's also I can upset
that [ __ ] discovery shows animals
don't [ __ ] watch Discovery Channel no
[ __ ] they show animals you buried
Hastings man cuz there are a lot of
corporations yeah but also for Reed
Hastings I love them but also you know
[ __ ] no but there's a lot of there's a
lot of pressure to take things too high
are we hard to defend not if you're not
for that works what else yet this Will
Smith his birthday was yesterday
and did a bungee jump off a helicopter
in the middle of the Grand Canyon what I
find amazing about Will Smith is right
he's so goddamn count that he's been
show Binns forever and just got on
Instagram like eight months ago and he
was like oh you youtubers and
personalities entertained precise think
you're really funny oh that's cool
what's this Instagram thing and then
just took girl like you guys the best
post it's great I mean but he's spending
tons of sadly guys all the resources to
make him awesome but it worked
of course birthday yesterday and he
jumped out of a plane jumped out of hell
and then his boy Carlton was the
announcer at work let's see it was all
live to livestream let me see it once
you watch it I'll have questions for you
please Jen so this is this is him in the
helicopter right now let's see how this
compared to Brian's 50th birthday party
right
he's standing on the on the skid of the
helicopter facing the inside of it it
looks damn good for 50 nagged at 4:30
yeah he looks young so he's about to go
I would never do this ever I'm nervous
ever he's nervous look at his face -
yeah he looks good throughout it he
actually looked like his super super
scared it's normal to be spunky he's a
good he said I have fun he goes not yet
not yet the hell cares not exactly
season connecting will bro-bro magic
that makes me scared could you do this
no I just said look at him go dude he
took off and his family's on that cliff
watching oh man the hue pops up move he
kept going look he kept on right into
the plane no I would never do this
pretty crazy alright I wouldn't go to
watch you guys do this alright that I
find this very boring I find it pretty
exhilarating though really yes I think
if you're doing it yeah I mean so that
was pretty much it they find a way to
land them later on that's hard to land
that way you guys here it's closer yeah
they just set him down yeah yeah they're
on hooks and there goes right that's
cool here's the thing though so the only
let a certain amount of people go to
this cliff all right yeah so it's people
that he knows and that are part of the
show and their family yeah not there I
know this is real but they never shoot
they never showed the helicopter and
Will Smith together it's just the him
and the cord and then the helicopter up
and then him in the cord on the bottom
the shots yeah so your first you're
thinking I'd do it chin I'm just saying
the Freddie Bravo say hear yourself out
the back if you're a video editor the
first thing you're thinking of is like
wait let me see them together at least
them together what they showed
jumping out of the helicopter just stop
that no they showed him falling like
this he facing the can doing okay could
that possibly be a green screen sure
couldn't no come on it's also not that
so well it's not that hard to do this
almost like off so it's not like he's
doing things that's easy
obviously they should have shown at
least the helicopter and him together
and one me like they're no they don't
show it
like that's okay that's it like that Tim
though that can easily be somewhat up
but why would you fake this I don't I'm
just saying it's just just a benefit uh
someone that's like a critical eye
where's helicopter well I mean well you
wouldn't see what they have to zoom out
too far also yeah you know photography
you'd have to zoom out so far you
couldn't tell that could be [ __ ] if
you were doing um if you guys are doing
this
1 million percent we would have cameras
showing both the helicopter and you guys
I mean I don't need that I think I don't
care like hopefully people don't COO
tickets we're not showing the helicopter
and Will Smith at the exact time that
Jim and I can understand that there
would be I mean just take away that and
then I'm a hundred percent like yeah
it's awesome but also not like he's it's
not like it's that crazy people bungee
jump all that there thousands of people
are bungee jumping right now chance it's
not like off the helicopter for sure no
I think he's the first one to do it
no in the Grand Canyon not a chance in
the Grand Canyon people have done it
before and I'll tell you what else he do
the highest fall like when the one that
the guy who did the highest might want
to YouTube that okay the highest
freefall into a bag and airbag he jumped
out of a helicopter
now the airbag apparently according to
him looked like a tic tac douche and he
had to jump and land just right or you
go right through the airbag right
through what scares the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of me yeah what makes sense for him to
fake that no I'm not say it's just show
the freaking you just wish they yeah cuz
they edited it better that's the number
one thing I was looking for when I was
watching it live and never showed it
would you say you're a hey where do you
see here I I want to be I want to be
like completely satisfied and I wasn't
so look there's no one else if
if a Will Smith video satisfy you you
got some issues in life here's 10
what else you got gin well it's mrs.
only one well no you put how many people
I'm sure if just put bungy jumping out
of our over Grand Canyon no not in the
helicopter though yeah I know do it do
bungee jumping Grand Canyon see what
comes up
you need all sorts options all Will
Smith keys the hottest right now but
there's a link for you to do it
skydive the Grand Canyon helicopter with
there's bridges and stuff over the grand
can you can do that too not helicopters
you guys can research it later it's not
that cool either it's like all right
it's not that crazy I wouldn't do it
it's not that crazy no when I first
heard that sounds like this is a
craziest thing you could do especially
for Will Smith really well I had jumped
out of a plane without a parachute and
landed a huge thing that was pretty
incredible
I don't watch anyone to it I don't know
why people get out like that didn't know
I was a girl's guy bungee jump out of a
helicopter right I guess I'll watch it
like Phoenix showed me and it was on my
mind I wouldn't click I don't all right
here's another would seven-year-old girl
at the LA Galaxy soccer game she's
saying that national meet her dude right
she's Asian she's so [ __ ] wait to see
this Brian this is what this is cool
you think this is fake too you [ __ ]
hater
can you see what keep watching whose
white stripes and stars oh my [ __ ]
god awesome
[Music]
incredible damn you're gonna love it
more
[Applause]
[Music]
why still there oh say does that
star-spangled
it's just astonishing I have a
seven-year-old you didn't wholly share
if it
[Applause]
stop it how cute is she that's that's
incredible super that's just incredible
and they cool yeah that's just
incredible Will Smith insurance Bob said
Will Smith's Drummond a helicopter hold
my beer oh that's amazing
that wasn't lip-syncing it was real
that's amazing Wow that itches
Wow that's it man those were good man
feels really good Brendan another
podcast huh buddy another one down
another one brother 100 huh we're almost
at 400 really a TV it's more like five I
was looking at you and I when we were we
did some stuff at box and burn some
self-defense
you had a shaved head you were still
fighting yeah and it was like that was a
long time ago
I know I know dude goddamn what's not
400 how's the podcast turn we still kick
an ass always kickin ass still doing
well who's tired always top five top
three is that right yeah in sports
killing this is a gift I've growing
growing growing dude as much time with
me though hurts my feelings a little bit
yeah you get on my nerves just real bi
yeah my [ __ ] nerves
anyways speaking of spending time in
growing um be spring timing growing in
Seattle Bellevue really Bellevue parlor
live this Thursday Friday Saturday and
the new dates and cities have just been
added in Utah wise guys in October then
I'm also in San Francisco November 2nd
and 3rd I've got him in Sacramento then
New Mexico just got added I'm coming to
New Mexico Wow I know I never been the
new meaning
well I've been there many club I'm not
sure I think it's casino New Mexico but
either way this Thursday Friday Saturday
how many dude parlor live Bellevue we
can do it two men I
shooting tea fat k calm alright guys
until next time this is a fine kid we're
out